[Musique]
enfin les enfants je devais le ronge
pont soit
est-ce que vous aidez les oraux je n'ai
bien sûr nounours les enfants aiment
beaucoup les arrange alors nicolas et
pimprenelle seront contents que les
importe pour eux un petit eiffel mais
repos pour bonsoir deviner mon premier
est un métal précieux
mon second est un habitant des cieux et
mon tout est un fruit délicieux deviner
ce que je vous à pau est pas laurence la
merci nos aînés vous savez que l'on veut
faire n'est pas de jour avec des oranges
la copie oui mais de là à
[Musique]
elles sont là les oranje du cem au plus
du quart des jus d'orange de jus
d'orange annoncer l'évangile comme ça on
les épluche c'est que moi je vais en vue
nicolas post couteau c'est dangereux
jamais un petit garçon doit toucher 1
tout comme ça
[Musique]
le petit feu alors qu'ils menaient 10
élus n'auront plus haut la pauvre on va
regarder dans une glace
tu verras comme iddri tu verras on est
je crois que rien bon voilà la preuve
[Musique]
tu ne vas pas voir jolis yeux dans la
glace que ça te fait non je ne bouge pas
[Musique]
beaucoup
moi j'ai quelque chose pour mon gros
nitoo ouais tiens
non là ça va mieux
oui pour faire clair nous allons nous
coucher tôt salle bonne et nano
[Musique]
en route nounours mais qu'est ce que tu
as tu pleures menault patron
j'ai deux bronzes de tous brillants
j'ai compris nicolas et pimprenelle ton
encore fait une farce
bonne nuit des enfants je ne vous
conseille pas de jouer avec les peaux
d'orange comme le font nos deux petits
amis or savent non chapic trolio allez
vite vous couchez sauge mot fait pour
[Musique]
oh
ouais
homo
[Musique]